why are there so many US bases on this
island in Japan the Battle of Okinawa
was one of the bloodiest specific
combats of the world the us-led campaign
lasted 82 days and killed tens of
thousands of Okinawans
up to 70,000 Japanese soldiers and
12,000 American soldiers were also
killed and the US military has had an
extensive presence on the island ever
since Okinawa Prefecture is home to more
than 70% of US military bases in the
country it's a strategic location for
the u.s. being close to Taiwan China and
the Korean Peninsula the bases are
controversial local women have been
raped by US servicemen leading to mass
protests people are also worried about
aircraft crashes pollution and excessive
noise the u.s. and Japan agreed to
relocate the Marine Corps Air Station
Futenma which is precariously located in
the middle of a metropolitan city by
moving it to the small fishing village
of Henoko but even moving the base is
causing problems an overwhelming
majority of Okinawans opposed the move
saying it'll disrupt the local community
and hurt the endangered Dewgong and
coral reef in the area
ever wonder why pacifism is deeply
embedded in the Japanese identity
well after world war two decimated
Imperial Japan